hi everybody I am Alexa ray Korea and I
am here with Mary Kish and we are
playing arguably one of the weirder
games we've played this year Omega
quintet now we stumbled upon this game
yeah it was kind of doing new releases
and found out that it's coming out on
the ps4 and thought I would thought I'd
give it a whirl I've been playing it all
morning
it's no there's there's a lot to unpack
here what you're seeing right now is the
opening it's not readily apparent yet
but this game was made by idea factory
compound heart they're the studio behind
fee Hyperdimension Neptunia games so you
can already expect something kind of
weird now I don't know what the plot is
so what is the story like what are we
getting into right now yeah so there's
something bad happening in the world and
it's like monsters are killing humanity
and it's up to these five song girls for
to save the world with their skills and
cuteness like goddamn I play with I play
as him when I'm in this area which is
like basically where we live this is our
office home this was the main girls what
is his relationship to so they grew up
together and they are best friends and
there has been so much alluding in the
story that they are flirting but they
refused to admit it so they're just kind
of I don't know they're just very
they're just friends damn it yeah they
refuse to admit anything but I mean
obviously there's there's some like high
school stuff going on there and then
there's missions there's a workshop I'll
show you this as well these are the
girls so I believe I'm gonna get five
okay currently I've unlocked two I've
I've unlocked Kennedy Co and Nene I am
Lata ha and that I'm the leader and I
basically just hold that I'm taking over
and I'm doing this I'm going to be an
Omega Quin tells me this is my outfit
outfits are really big here
just to show you how weird the game is
like obviously you can shoot this their
their headbands and their underwear is
part of it
yeah she looks great here's Nene with
her awesome gun and then that's tacked
some my best friend's hair loose little
boy who I have no sexual attraction to
none whatsoever no yeah so they each
have different skill sets and underwear
and outfits so this is is kind of like
I'm kind of figuring this out too still
I've been playing as you can see on the
lower right for a three and a half hours
Oh Mary in that three and a half hours I
still feel like I am in a tutorial I'm
still figuring out so much I don't this
is like the first time ever played
anything like this what is affection
this is interesting I have affection
meters for tax and all the girls but
they're not connected to the girls
aren't connected to each other so it's
not really so much how the girls feel
about each other but how much they feel
about him which is interesting so he's
kind of like the pimp of the group and I
need to make sure that they all have
affection towards me I believe that
helps their strength later on in the
game
with you know how when they save the
world yeah I need their pimp
they need their pimp to save the world
it's hard out there there's a lot of
story this is momoka this is the girl I
replaced who's too old to do it are you
kidding me she seems like this tiny
little girl she's returned she's retired
she just retired and she hates us
because we're really young and cute so
right now she's yelling at me for not
doing enough I'm loafing around
oh gosh Oh such an angry little girl she
looks fine to me
she is she's pretty nice um Oh Blair is
the monsters that I'm killing that's
what she's talking about like how I've
saved you from the Blair
I saved you somewhere there's a [ __ ]
time a dialogue I sometimes just start
to burn through it a little bit that's
all basically what I'm getting from this
conversation is that she hates me and
she thinks I'm a worthless sack of butt
well she her skin is apparently bad yeah
I should tell her that this again is bad
Oh your grandma so get out of my way
oh my god that's kind of upsetting to me
as someone in there look well going into
their late 20s this game has just begun
if that upsets you you're in for a real
treat
so I'm distracted by the boob jiggle I'm
sorry I'm just gonna say it yeah I wish
I would have had it earlier there was a
scene where kind of dick I like put a
toe ha in her breasts and like shoved
her in there and I turned around and
every person in the office was staring
everybody screaming oh gosh but there
was much boobs on it it was good oops I
don't even know what's happening all the
time the dialogue has no value really
that's upsetting the story is so weird
so what you're building right now is
like the typical RPG party of like your
healer and your tank and your whatever I
think so who's this guy this is the guy
who helps clear out all the people who
could get in my way of a dangerous
battle
she always lifts her arms like that so
smooth armpits she's young she's got
those young armpits good skin armpits
I died before I had to look after verse
maidens he she's like a protector kind
of guy he's got some chest eve going on
- yeah he's he's good-looking blokes I'm
heck what would you call it PEC jiggle
PEC keeping man cleavage man Cleve
that's like got a little shiny me that
[ __ ] yeah me that's the sweat from him
working hard
it's me [ __ ] forever now assume I
represent my party kind of like in a lot
of RPGs I guess I owe you get to run
around freely yeah it says those are bad
guys here I want to show you this is
pretty good this is me the camera can
kind of look under her a little bit nah
oh my G is she gets mad at me when I do
that listen she'll say stuff like not
looking don't mean you shouldn't do
things I gave you this game of came
after me no her beer at is gonna get his
so on this is the first time I've ever
actually attacked with all these three
different girls so I assume I get to
attack for each of them
although oh look it shows on the right
side like it orders them like when they
attack cameras where it's nice you turn
base right that's correct so if you look
right on the action you'll see all these
circles for the different people who get
their option to attack if you look
there's a monster yes if you keep going
down to the left there's like a purple
sphere that says 25 that means when it's
that person's action turn they get that
bonus oh nice so there's times when I
actually need to skip a turn or avoid or
just make sure the monster doesn't get
that bonus on one of my party gets that
bonus so yeah there's like some
interesting pieces to it all right so
that's where melee move based games I'll
show you all their their their standard
attacks just so you can you can you move
the camera around oh it's kind of gosh
what the head of not good
Wow way to go you I like this UI is
weird it's also very like good work
everyone
really want it takes up a lot of the
screen there's a lot of UI like clutter
there is a lot there is a lot I know
yeah I forgot that a rat attacked me
while I was looking up her skirt there's
a lot of sorry oh well she didn't like
her she doesn't like when I do that I
find it funny that they made a very
fanservice e game but you can't look up
anyone's skirt that's true that's like
that's like she yell at you to she she's
not having it so they all they each have
skills as well energy skills and mic
skills I'm not really sure exactly I
love how it it tells you how long you're
not to wait after you use it so she's
got like this physical skill I'll just
show you because I've never seen them
anyway so I'd like to see them and see
what they look like
well that that does a decent amount of
damage that was interesting so I could
probably yeah and then so her skill is
incinerate so I'll do it on this one so
we can kill this rat so this is like a
fire move and it does
875 damage said I'm really effective
against rats I I also in real life rats
are immune they just do not like fire no
because the rats just explode so she's
got heal and cleanse I don't know what
that is
Oh a mouse moves like status effects um
it looks like she's got a little bit of
alchemy and then I'll show you so she's
got some skills like skill I'll try this
archers bullet on this guy and see how
good it is oh it's okay total damage Wow
whew sometimes it's funny when they
attack us they'll say stuff like not my
face the girls get upset when the
attacks fair I'll just do some melee
moves because each of those special
moves will take SP and I only have so
much now I can always get more SP by I
think I I take a vitamin I take some
vitamin A vitamin supplement I take a
vitamin supplement and that increases my
Espie I can also have a I think it's
called like a sports drink
it's how I increase my HP Wow
do you mean and do anything in
particular
she needs tact oh my god because they
love each other
so why is he not fight he's there with a
sword why is he not fighting ok so I
didn't use him because these fights are
like silly easy but when you're in like
the battle if you hit X at a particular
time tact will come up and do a
follow-up move it's kind of like a
support of course up type oh that's why
at what yeah like they're basically
they're always accusing him of the way
you were doing it for me like you always
do they like kind of fight over them a
little bit come on do you want me to try
to get hurt so I lose my outfit get get
naked get naked marry okay oh all right
okay let's sec what's sacrifice one of
them okay one of them just get really
wonder how I can make him okay so I
changed my outfit right now but I don't
have anything to change into I can
change the order and I can do the pair
change yeah no wait
so he's paired up with her right now I
suppose but I don't change pair change
what marry for him today okay I got
there we go
I changed it my goodness
funny too because they were just
complaining about how he only helps a
toe huh and I just changed it back to
her because they love each other and how
dare you get in the way right [ __ ]
okay
so he's pretty strong doesn't look like
we're doing a lot of damage what she
needs to calm down but this is your job
honey
you signed up for this it makes her
nervous yeah
deal with it deal with it
God sometimes you gotta go to work
sometimes what should I do
sometimes you gotta gotta just suck it
up you guys suck it up girl so you'd be
a good manager me yeah I'd be just like
put on some goddamn clothes and get out
there naked mole bright only one of them
oh I see only one can be naked today so
wait if you how do you call him out do
you hit oh oh right so I forgot I can
only do it when the other guys doing or
when the because he's supporting that
girl oh can we can we switch him back to
I mean she was bitching about it earlier
being like no why don't you help me I am
so long no I'm not allowed to change oh
wow okay well no he's stuck so far just
use more I'm gonna increase let's see
what her Mike's bills are Brio blasts
welcome is a oh this is all so confusing
but that range
it says Circle D or power is BDD B so
the closer it is to a is the more
powerful it is and then it's s SS is the
most powerful so it's like the opposite
of cup size of bras like okay yeah
smaller the more powerful I just you
know what the theme that's all
I don't like this girl at all yes she's
coming into her powers and her body like
alright I'm sure a teenage girl I'm
already like no one actually talks like
that I'm not in love with the with the
localisation funny gage Cuse lifted her
arms up she loves it a sweet sweet young
pits arms young pig young pitch showing
off for young that'll be that'll be the
name of the sequel Omega Concetta jump
it young Pitts
oh those teenage insecurities how can I
ever survive
oh my god what what is you like some
pretty dangerous stuff
wait why oh my god this dialogue is just
like rout like it taught like they talk
insert an episode of Degrassi and oh my
god
younger and more saving the world they
already said that it's a weapon people
can't get ahold of stop talking about it
nobody cares oh this is where I can like
increase the skills of my character or I
think I just gained new get you hot a
fire feels good so I've been going into
doing any like melee moves with her
because you're trying to keep them in
sync you know yeah in sync
like good not like the bad like the boy
bands oh my god this game berserk
assault that sounds good I can't use any
of them I still can't get past the fact
that this is a game about like oh you're
like a young won't like you're too old
to fight so here are some 12 year olds
told year olds that's the story that are
good on one riddled with sexual tension
are you jelly no I think it's awful it's
okay if you're gel of their young skin
okay
I don't ever want to be 12 ever again
I'm totally fun and fast that especially
if they have to like save the world like
I like to go home at the end of the day
and like knock back a bottle and like
just do my own thing yeah I'm really
comfortable with my old hair and ability
to drink alcohol like going a bit at 9'o
I'm comfortable with my my my had years
my egg here we're good it's all downhill
from here oh yeah I wanted to show you
this oh so this is if you go to the
right here you can be diet master which
I assume it helps keep the girls trim
and looking hot so I've been master I've
been trying to earn my way up there I'm
getting there insomnia it's right next
to insomniacs lullaby that's where you
can sing them to sleep to get them to
calm down and shut up
so that's a mega quintet
um it's out no it is out you can you can
go to the store and get this for ps4 and
take it home to your bedroom and maybe
not let anyone see you buy it for your
living room or whatever it yes this is
it I think I showed you most of the
highlights I mean it's it's it's a it's
interesting it's it's an it's an
interesting interesting game if you're
interested in this type of fighting
style and changing out their outfits and
scoping that out you can totally pick
this up look at me
what do you think that in two words man
enough with cotton magical cotton is it
breathable breathable and defensive and
it makes her be able to hold up this
giant gun she's she's a cutie I made it
oh yeah let's end on that oh yeah I'm on
the guy it's equal yeah